à quoi ressemble donc cette nouvelle
hongrie qui devient ainsi quarante ans
plus tard le premier pays de l'est a
rejeté le régime communiste à part sens
de cette société qui s'ouvre au
capitalisme mais qui fonctionne déjà à
plusieurs vitesses jacques merlino et
jean corneille en reviennent et oui
anglais aussi il faut savoir prendre son
mal en patience et attendre
mais cette fois pour une toute autre
raison nous sommes ici au tribunal de
commerce budapest là où l'on dépose les
statuts des nouvelles sociétés
tous les matins les files d'attentes
sont si longue qu'il a fallu décider de
ne faire entrer les candidats que 10 par
dix nous n'arrêtons pas des sept avocats
d'affaires globaux chaque semaine ou de
vous mettre au point la construction
juridique d'une dizaine d'entreprises
ça va très vite en ce moment très vite
c'est un peu le leitmotiv de ce pays
il y a deux mois par exemple 'le sans
voir décide de monter une maison de
production de films
aujourd'hui il a une trentaine de
salariés et boucle son deuxième long
métrage la technique chacun qui gâtent
quand on permet aux gens de vivre selon
leurs capacités intellectuelles
alors ils deviennent capables de tout
aujourd'hui ce ne sont que des petites
îles mais viendra le moment où ces
petites îles se rejoindront et formeront
un continent ou encore agnès pas cathy
elle a créé une ligne de vêtements
gagnent beaucoup d'argent et est un peu
le symbole nouvelle hongrie si j'ai
commencé il y a deux ans j'étais l'une
des premières à voula créer une
entreprise privée mais aujourd'hui je
veux rester comme je suis et surtout ne
pas trop m'agrandir
mais cette effervescence de création
d'entreprise ne concerne que les
services là où il faut peu de capitaux
et ou avec de la chance et du travail on
peut gagner gros
et vite mais dans l'industrie personne
ne va et les grandes usines sont à
l'état d'abandon vieilles machines
vieilles structures vieux produits plus
personne n'en veut et l'économie
hongroise se retrouve de ce fait de plus
en plus endettés par tête d'habitant
c'est le pays de l'est qui doit le plus
à l'étranger
et c'est bien cela qui explique en
partie le manque de confiance deux ans
croient en leur avenir les jeunes
expriment à leur manière en transformant
les usines dessert en lieu de fête
triste et quelque peu désespéré cette
boîte s'appelle le trou noir
ils sont plusieurs centaines à s'y
retrouver chaque soir sous le slogan
nous n'avons pas d'avenir
la politique moi je m'en fiche et la vie
aussi
une fois j'essaie de me pendre le
suicide chez les jeunes c'est très à la
mode bluff peut-être mais il est certain
que les hongrois comme les polonais ont
du mal à croire que cette fois ça y est
ils sont sortis de quarante ans de
dictature
le traumatisme des répressions de 58 68
80 sont trop forts encore vous permettre
une confiance totale
la fin du